[Music]
Universal basic income is an idea that's
older than America where Thomas Payne
was for it at the founding of the
country called it the citizens dividend
decade later Martin Luther King jr. was
for it he championed it before he was
assassinated in 1968 and Milton Friedman
and a thousand economist I'm the studies
in the late 60s saying this would be
tremendous for both the economy and
society it received so much support that
it passed the House of Representatives
twice under Richard Nixon in 1971 and
the only reason it didn't become law was
that Democrats in the Senate wanted an
even higher income threshold so a
universal basic income has been with
this country for a long time and it
actually became law in one state in 1982
where now every person in Alaska gets
between one and two thousand dollars a
year no questions asked from a petroleum
dividend it's wildly popular has created
thousands of jobs has improved
children's health has decreased income
inequality it was passed by a Republican
governor who made this argument to the
Alaskan people who would you rather get
the oil money the government who's just
gonna mess it up or you and the Alaskan
people said us and now it's so popular
that a majority of Alaskans which is a
deeply conservative state generally the
majority of Alaskans said they would
accept higher taxes to pay for this
dividend moving forward my plan the
freedom dividend would pay every
American adults starting at age eighteen
$1,000 a month or $12,000 a year this
would push every American adult to just
below the poverty line which is twelve
thousand seven hundred seventy dollars a
year right now but this money would get
spent in Main Street businesses on car
repairs food and tutoring for your kids
the occasional night out a hardware
store it would go right back into our
economy it would create 2 million new
jobs would grow the consumer economy by
eight to ten percent would make our
families and communities stronger would
improve children's health and nutrition
would improve everyone's mental health
and productivity it would decrease
domestic violence and hospital visits so
universal basic income is a powerful
policy that helps improve human welfare
and that's why I'm proposing it
proposing it as the centerpiece of my
candidacy for president so the way I
propose to pay for a universal basic
income is based on a problem we have
right now in our country which is that
more and more work and values getting
sucked up and soaked up by a handful of
technology companies Amazon for example
is doing another twenty billion dollars
in commerce every year and it's now
pushing 30 percent of American malls and
Main Street stores into closing and so
for the average American you're seeing
your Main Street stores closed and
unfortunately being a retail worker is
the most common job in the United States
the average retail worker is a 39 year
old woman making between 11 and 12
dollars an hour so the problem America
is facing is that even as Amazon soaking
up more and more value they're not
paying much in the way of taxes you
probably saw the headline where last
year Amazon enjoyed record profits and
paid zero in federal taxes and so the
way we pay for a universal basic income
is we put the American people in
position to benefit from all this
innovation by passing a value-added tax
which is something that's already in
effect in every other advanced economy
with a value-added tax the American
public would receive a sliver of every
Amazon sale every Google search every
Facebook ad every robot truck mile and
because our economy is now so vast at 20
trillion dollars up five trillion in the
last 12 years alone a value-added tax
that even half the European level would
generate 800 billion in revenue which
combined with current spending economic
growth from putting this buying power
into Americans hands cost savings on
things like incarceration homelessness
services and emergency room health care
and then the value gains from having a
stronger more educated more productive
more entrepreneurial population there's
one study that showed that if you were
to reduce reduce poverty in this country
you would actually be increasing GDP by
700 billion dollars just by making
people stronger healthier better
educated and mentally healthier and so
we're going to be able to pay for this
universal basic income if we put in a
new tax that harnesses the gains of all
these new technological innovations and
brings them back
the American people
[Music]